Adult program rating here for
leadership from the campus and
then we're gonna open up to
student testimony or anyone
who's here would like to share
their thoughts can.
Do that so all to visually take
the gavel up.
Signal to the audio video crew.
Okay so we're gonna officially
call the Senate.
Select committee on student
success to order here in
Sacramento state. To be here
this is a part of our a two year
long tour of college campuses
around California.
That focuses on the issues of
student needs -- As it relates
to food as it relates to housing.
As it relates to mental health.
And also importantly as it
relates to the ability of
students to get through and get
their degree -- And for years
I'm joined on this panel by many
distinguished leaders here from
this area from the state.
On my right senator pan on my
left senator McCarty both
representing Sacramento state in
the legislature.
And on my far left center Allen --
A member of the Senate from
southern California former chair
of the Senate Education
Committee.
So prior to this hearing we all
of us participated in tours of
the campus in different select
areas we heard.
A few minutes ago from center
pan on the four year graduation.
Rate issue and we're gonna hear
a lot more from the testimony in
just a couple minutes.
We are from Senate assembly
member McCarty about basic needs
in the new food pantry here at
Sacramento state certainly a
point of pride to have it.
That it comes in an
uncomfortable moment because so
many students are -- Not not
able to get some basic food
needs met and that's the the
advantage of having that the
pantry here -- And then of
course the area of mental health
and senator Allen and I I got a
chance to tour -- The the well
the student health and
counseling service center it's
very impressive by you know bill.
From student fees -- Trying to
treat the whole student and it's
a it's a very impressive.
Solidity no one of the fax --
Unfortunate facts about student
life and our colleges today.
Is that 16% of the students at
the state university system all
twenty three campuses 16% --
Receive some sort of
psychological counseling or
treatment on campuses last year.
Extinguish sent.
And when we went through the the
well here this morning and we
got the facts about how many
students are treated it's a it's
a large number that's great over
thirty thousand students have
visited the what the well
Saturday.
At to deal with that urgent care
needs -- Medical needs medicines
and certainly counseling.
And and when the survey to
understand what was the number
one reason for visiting.
At the top issue.
Was depression and anxiety.
Depression and anxiety.
And I and I have learned Jeff
both in my previous services a
trustee of the state
universities and as a parent --
Date if you have a student that
is a struggling -- And stressed
out for whatever reason.
That it could it could really
stop complete stop.
There at their education.
Is that things aren't together
whatever it is -- Sometimes you
just can't go to that class and
you can't take that test.
And unfortunately statewide the
ability of a student to be seen
quickly -- Is very very poor.
In some cases up to three weeks
think about that you're in a
state of crisis.
And it takes you three weeks to
get a point.
But one of the purposes of our
college tour is is to learn.
At where things are going right.
And we want to celebrate that
and with things aren't doing so
well I mean one apartment trying
to make it better.
But I'm really pleased to hear
in my my visits with the
leadership of the counseling
center that if you're a student
here at Sacramento state.
And you're in crisis that
someone is going to be able to
see you that day.
That's the model that they've
created -- They called it the
the urgent care.
A model.
That I it's not just about
getting an appointment where you
can sit down for an hour.
If it's someone struggling that
day whether it's balancing your
bank account.
Or being stressed out about a
class that here at Sacramento
state you can see you can meet
with somebody and talk that
issue through.
Immediately.
And it's very impressive and I
hope the tape take the model
that you've used to do that
because it hasn't come
necessarily with more money.
But with their adjustment of how
you deal with.
These types of mental health.
And counseling challenges I know
we're gonna hear from some of
your leadership about that.
But there were seven thousand
visits here at Saks State.
Opera counseling.
And while it seems like a lot.
You know that they're getting
taken care of means that.
It's going to affect so many
other things to talk about the
whole person.
And the ability to stay in
school.
And that's gonna be reflected a
graduation rates -- And low debt
and all kinds of other things
that relate.
To that help with that that was
very impressive to me I know
there's other things to say in a
debrief.
About trying to tap into the
resources center Allen anything
you wanted to add to that before
we begin how.
Well I you know wanted to
obviously thank everyone for
helping to put all this together
at yeah I don't know if anyone
saw but the lead story in the
Sacramento bee.
Is office basically the findings
of a of a very -- Contemporary
recent you see Berkeley study
that shows that anxiety
depression and stress among
college students are at epidemic.
Levels.
And the two major issues at the
the article the report cites is.
The extraordinary amount of data.
And financial security that
students are currently dealing
with you have a lot of folks
coming in from -- Already
financially precarious positions
and then we make their position
even more precarious by just.
You know how asking them to
finance a a public education or
education.
That's the first thing the
second thing interestingly.
Is.
Social media -- Phones.
Computers the extent to which we
are isolating ourselves in ways
that previous generations have
not.
It's interesting this generation
is physically safer.
Because bye bye bye mentally --
More insecure because folks are
so.
Delved in to the world -- The
virtual world.
And and it leads to a whole
series of of psychological
challenges mental challenges.
That were all scrambling to try
to help address.
On the financial side of course.
You know we're all working on
trying to improve the situation
I you know some of the bill
ideas were brought up -- You
know one of these I'd love to
work on is it.
Yeah tax write off for since our
tax credit for de. For student
debt.
I love to work with these
numbers on on that -- Wiener
it's integration I working on
better coordination.
And data collection associated
with our higher educational
systems that we can do a better
job.
Of understanding the needs of
students today and and having
better articulation through the
K. to twelve system the cal
state and when.
Houses do twenty going to grad
school elsewhere how do we help
make that system work better.
Then of course -- You try to
reduce costs in general -- And
have really strong health
infrastructure in place and I
was I was impressed to see --
The the extent to which the well
is is really stepped up I love
the fact that even grades with
physical health and on the other
wall and all that the cold --
I've you know.
Worked out facilities that are
there also the fact that mental
health counseling and and some
of the other more traditional
medical care is in the same
place.
As one of things we talk about
the tour is that there's a quite
a stigma associated with.
Getting counseling -- But if you
go to the ER nobody you know
there's no stigma associated
with I don't know if you got a
hi you have some sort of minor --
Physical ailment that needs
addressing -- It's it's nice not
to have to say -- Counseling
over there.
You know.
Other types of care over here
that that's something that
sometimes lead students did not
want to go into the counseling
room because they're a little.
Yeah they're they're worried
about the stigma their little
bit Joel sheepish about it so
integrating man understanding
that there is a health and
wellness nexus that is so strong
and so important for us to
understand.
Was great now it really is a
reflection of kind of best
practices in the field so.
You know I'm we're all
struggling to help make the
system work better for young
people we have not made it easy
I mean it is just extraordinary
to me how much.
I think about my parents'
generation and the extent to
which society stepped up to
provide.
Low cost high quality public
education for them and how we
have just eaten away at that
promise that is inherent master
plan over the decades.
It is such a shame is such a it
does such an injustice to the
next generation and also doesn't
it just as to what to us as a
society because a really does
the track from.
Students ability to grow and
thrive once they get out of
school and start a business and
buy a house and build a family
and all the kinds of things that
we associate with the American
dream self -- That's part of why
we're here tomorrow I was part
of this committee and and and
and just try to learn in fact
finding try to get information
from you.
So that we can help to promote
better policies that will --
Will assist you on the ground
here on this campus enough with.
Great thank you center Allen so
let's let's begin with our for
our first panel like to invite
app -- The following that in
fact you know who you are so
come on up here and sit down and
I'll introduce you so president
Nelson come on joy in the well
and said rock completes comes to
death.
Please come join us yeah.
And we're gonna live.
We're gonna someone.
We're gonna start with that with
the president Nelson -- Hi.
It's it's somewhat argue you
know we finish a legislative
career what did you do that
really mattered or not mattered
but it's arguable that maybe the
most important thing I ever did.
Was service the chair of the
presidential selection committee
here in Sacramento state -- And
would together with my
colleagues on the board of
trustees -- Selected that Robert
Nelson to be your president here
in Sacramento.
And it may be the most important
decision I've ever made because
of the great job that you are
doing Sir.
And it's been a pleasure to to
follow -- Your leadership.
Over the last two years and and
making a big difference I know
there's a lot of things you're
very excited about that are
happening here we're gonna hear
from.
In a moment but we thank you for
your graciousness and having
that Senate simply here -- On
the campus and we look forward
to hearing your thoughts about
these important issues of basic
needs and and that'll help them.
Graduation and all the rest of
president Nelson walk.
It's an honor to address you
today thank you for coming de
sac state senators and
assemblyman carting.
We are honored to have you here
and we're honored to be able to
show you a little bit about our
campus and what we're trying to
do -- When you did hire me?
I open up the hood of the car
and we showed everybody what was
inside and that was an 8%
graduation rate.
I'm very proud to say that we
are currently at a fourteen
point 7%.
And just making that small
change if you do back of the
envelope.
Numbers it's saved our students
ninety three million dollars
they would have to pay intuition
just making that little change
we are now predicting that we
will be at 21%.
In the September of this year
that's a four year graduate as a
four year graduation rate.
We've already broken all of the
other moves as far as it goes
were 10% higher than the system
thought we were going to be in
twenty twenty five four or four
years -- For six year graduation
rates and we're just moving
forward how did we do it we
added a thousand new classes we
could never added those thousand
new classes without the help of
the legislature.
The graduation initiative gave
us the money to be able to add
those classes.
That thousand classes cost six
point two million dollars.
With out the graduation
initiative we would not have
been there.
We then added a hundred and
seventy seven new faculty we
added advisors and we are moving
the needle.
For but it's not about
graduating in four years as you
said it's about having the
opportunity to graduate in four
years.
Many students will not.
Will never be a 100% graduation
for years will never be 70%
graduation M. for years we care
about all of our students.
And that means we have to care
about their mental health and we
have to care about what they are
doing and how they're moving
forward.
We care about the students who
are homeless the ramp.
In Sacramento.
Keeps going up we know that.
So even with the cal grants
we're never going to be able to
help on all those ways there.
Are maybe Jean C. housing
program has six beds in it
students can come and stay there
for up to thirty days that's not
a lot of beds but it makes a
difference and we're working
with everybody around here.
In the area to help the students
the student emergency grant.
Which often prevents
homelessness a student can go in
and get something maybe it's for
a higher that's out maybe it's
for medicines that they can't
afford.
Maybe it's for rent that there
maybe it's that book that they
just couldn't get.
We've got Ted grant and their
their over a hundred students
signed up for cal grant.
How fresh this year already so
we're trying to provide as many
services we can?
We have our counselors not only
in the well that you saw today.
But also in engineering also in
the dreamers resource center
also it in athletics so that
they can be out there and help
in every place that we can.
This next year we're going to
add one in Lassen hall which is
this one stop center for our
students so we care about the
students we care about them
being successful.
I have a great.
Group of in people of panel it's
going to come up.
You'll see how honest are.
And how much they really do care
because we are a Hornet family
so thank you for having us here
today.
And I'm sorry but I better do
stingers up.
At present Nelson thank you for
that sharing at the that great
progress eight from 8% four year
graduation rate 214%.
Last year with the with the hope
and belief it's going. To go up
220% so that's that's fantastic
assembly member ID I do have a
question need in this year's C.
S. U. budget.
They there is -- Scott fifteen
million dollars for some these
basic needs initiatives.
And it's it's one time
unfortunately.
Ironically the C. S. you see --
Budget item is the same fifteen
but on going so.
We were trying to make that I'm
going which would be of course
nice for the C. C. system twenty
three campuses.
If the what's the difference
what you can do one time verses
on going in other words are
there.
You can get I'm I'm sure the I
know the answer but you know
ongoing initiatives and you can --
Have.
Some -- Consistency and in
finding knowing that that can be
viable year after year.
I'm going money means that we
can hire people that will be
here to provide services on
going okay you can't hire people
on one time money.
You can hire him for a few
months.
But then you just hiring
adjuncts or something like that
and that is what we want to do
we will we will put the money
that if it is one time into
programs we'll put it into
counseling sessions we'll put it
into improving the pantry even.
More than what we're doing well
add some beds but it will be
short term.
So we very much want to have on
going sounds.
Great trying to make that happen
thank you.
He's the guy I know that in the
assembly.
All right -- Let you hang tight
we're gonna hear from a couple
other folks -- Joys Stewart
James -- Exact it is the
executive director of the
student health and counselling
services joy.
Thank you for your leadership --
And such an important area with
forty hearing your remarks.
Good morning thank you so much
for taking the time -- To see a
facilities and what what what
we're trying to work on towards
our students -- One of the
things that -- We try to do
about eight years ago we tried
to shift our focus from being
what we would consider a illness
driven or response kind of model
to a much more proactive
holistic -- Approach to
providing services and over the
last -- Really eight years we
look for ways to integrate -- To
give you some numbers -- Eight
years ago roughly 2222% of our
student population was accessing
the health center and less than
223% was using the counseling
center -- We've grown 55258% of
our student population routinely
accesses our health center
services.
And 7210% access our counseling
And through that approach we've
had to really -- Broaden our
efforts on prevention screening
prevention and early
intervention and five years ago
we began we decided that the top
presenting problems when we
looked at the medical side and
we looked at the counseling side.
To anxiety and depression were
in the top five for both and it
was at that point that we said
you know we're treating the same
patients we need to have a much
more coordinated approach on how
we do this.
So we began screening and we
screen our students for
depression on the medical side.
And really through a grant --
The cal mesa grand we establish
the urgent care model which was
one where students either
presenting -- For distress or
those that scored high on the
depression screening are in fact
seen -- That day that.
Immediately -- From that we
began looking at other data and
found that 30% of our student
population only really needs one
counseling appointment so just
this fall we implemented single
session visits which will allow
some students. To come in for
more problem solving kinds of
things so -- It's as as she
center Allen mention those of
the issues the demand --
Continues we have to continue to
look -- For ways to change our
service delivery on how we
provide services to students --
And expand -- You know the
number of programs -- That we
have.
The the more recent thing we did
this fall that I think -- Is is
interesting it is we adopted the
screening program that many --
Healthcare facilities are using
which is identifying food and
security.
So all of our students that come
into the health center our
screen for food and security
this fall.
We I just have the phone numbers
and we screen -- To over roughly
shy of four thousand students
and 31% of those students --
Were screened as possible for
food and security and so we were
able to do an immediate referral
over to the cares office and get
the students connected -- With
cow freshen the food pantry and
so I think that's a great way
for us all to be working
together to early identify
students that might not go to
the pantry initially but come to
the health center -- So we're
continually looking for ways for
us to cross can -- Collaborate
on those things.
That thank you joy joy and thank
you could.
C. L. what a beautiful facility
you have to work with their so I
know that's just part of the
issue -- In terms a terrified
and they care that **** that we
all want to provide.
I I I noted that the lesson is
here the dean of students.
And you have a big portfolio
here on campus and go way beyond
just -- Mental health and and
healthcare services but at
what's going well what's not
going so well what can you share
with us.
Thank you good morning
[inaudible]
I'm.
I I. frequently side of I'm very
commonly discussed C. S. T. wide --
Study that was done I'm sure
you're all familiar with it --
It's projected that C. S. U.
wide approximately forty one
point 6% of students reported
experiencing food and security
in the past twelve months --
Over twenty one point six of
those students reported very low
access to food.
Additionally ten point 9% of
students reported experiencing
homelessness in the past twelve
months those are staggering
numbers when we think about.
The the enormity of our system
and we're certainly seeing those
those numbers bear out here at
Sacramento state.
Some of the things that we do to
address this crisis and a number
of years ago I'd say probably
five or six years ago we we
surveyed and students who left
school.
After the first year -- Stopped
out we noticed that the vast
majority of them were in good
academic standing most people
assume that if students left
school it was because they found
out.
That wasn't the case so we we
sent out an exit survey of all
this to all the students who'd
left to ask why did they leave
what what went wrong if their
grades were were okay.
And what they overwhelmingly
said the top number.
On the top reason that students
left school after their first
year work was physical hardship
financial hardship.
So we wrap our heads around that
problem a little bit and and we
ask more questions in the
financial hardships weren't that
large we're not talking about
thousands of dollars that the
students were missing we're
talking about sometimes just a
few.
Hundred so that so a couple of
years and into my time here we
instituted something called in
at the student emergency grant
it's now called the Robert us
next Nelson.
Student emergency grant.
I'm not grant was established to
help students when when they've
experienced some kind of crisis
that forced them to make a
choice between continuing in
school.
Or or addressing the problem --
Or paying their rent or eating
that month no one should have to
make that choice.
So.
Not for five years ago we
instituted the emergencies grant
is really our first step in a
long line of services that we've
since created. To address these
kinds of issues for our students
and keep them in school and keep
them I'm working toward their
goals.
Shortly after the emergency
grant was instituted we created
our emergency housing program.
Doctor Nelson pointed out that
we have six spends on campus
they're always full so we've
seen so every year we see
approximately fifty students who
stay on campus for approximately
thirty days as emergency stopgap
housing while they C. case
manager to secure a longer term.
Resources in addition there are
some students who aren't able to
stay on campus maybe they have a
dependent -- Maybe they have a
small child in a residence hall
is inappropriate for them so we
instituted an agreement with a
local motel for for housing
vouchers to supplement.
So that all of our students can
be equally served.
Joy mentioned the the wonderful
partnership we have with student
health and counselling the
screening her her screening.
Program has referred to a great
number of students we project
that over two hundred and fifty
of those students will have been
registered for cal French fresh
services this year. To your
point.
Assembly member McCarty that's
that's teaching to fish instead
of giving the fish for the day.
We also provide.
Have an annual clothing drive
for students and we provide
financial coaching.
So it's very difficult to make a
small number of dollars stretch
but we work with our students to
teach them all sorts of ways. To
make the most of the resources
that they have access.
To I think the thing that that.
I'm most excited about is our
comprehensive case management
services.
So a little over three years ago
we had the the ability to bring
on a very talented case manager
from from our community.
And the reason this became a
game changer is because the
office the cares office that you
toward this morning became a
single point of contact for
students.
Many of whom are are suffering
from multiple challenges at once
not just one they don't fit
neatly into one of these
services when when you
experience one challenge I'm
sure you know he experienced
several.
And so the the students for the
who are the most impacted the
students who have.
The most complex issues are able
to see one person who can unpack
all of the different issues an
axe to help them to access the
many different resources that
they may sometimes need.
In order to get things put in
place in order for them to
continue to be successful and
fed and housed.
In that office -- If you have an
opportunity to see it we have
lockers because sometimes
homeless students need to make
use of our of our local shelters.
And sometimes they're free to do
that because they they may worry
about theft of a laptop or if
they're expensive textbooks so
we have lockers for students to
be able to lock their valuables
and in order. To to be as
resourceful as they can to meet
their housing needs we have
mailboxes so that if your if
your housing is in securing you
don't have a permanent mailing
address.
You have the opportunity to get
your mail so that some of the
services that have been put in
place don't get cut off because
you missed an important notice.
These students are followed
throughout the year.
They're given every resource
available and I'm happy to say
that even though they're some of
the most complicated situations
that we encounter on campus.
They haven't over over 87% of
them continue to stay in school
or graduate at the end of each
semester.
And those are the most
complicated cases that we see so
we know this model works we know
that it's helping people to stay
in school and we know that it's
helping people. To achieve a
brighter future thank you for
all of your support because the
S. B. eighty five funds were
funds that were used. To create
the cares space and everything
that Senate today so we thank
you for your support.
And the evidence of your
investment in our students by
being here in engaging with us
in this conversation.
Thank you I. D. lease and that.
It's great to hear about your
case management work and the
impact that can have on on the
whole student and and certainly
the emergency grants in the
housing vouchers and clothing
drive in the financial literacy
all those things are.
Really add up to a big number.
In keeping kids in school and
keeping them focused.
On their degree attainments and
then.
All that that leads to so --
Great leadership we really
appreciate it.
And we appreciate all your
insight any questions before we
continue with our okay.
Let.
Me invite that -- No well mora
the president of the Sacramento
state associate students -- You
have a a challenging job.
I know because I used to be in
that job forty years ago --
State university but hopefully
you're having fun to but we
appreciate your insight.
And your commitment to your your
fellow students and look for
here testing like this morning.
Thank you welcome.
Well thank you and good morning
to all of you senators and
assembly members that are here.
Actually gonna take the Mike --
And I want to thank my fellow
panelists and really all of the
students that are -- Here today
too because it is an
overwhelming timing for that
same reason I think you -- For
visiting and and really
listening to our student
concerns as they relate to
student basic needs it shows
your leadership and for that I
think you.
I think it's important really to
begin by setting an overview of
our student needs.
And as Beth mentioned we know
that about 10% of our students
system wide.
Were -- Don't know where they're
going to sleep in any given
night -- Whether that means that
their couch surfing.
Where they're out right homeless?
We know that about 47% of our
students here at sac state which
is higher than the system wide
average experience exile
eighteen over where they're
going to whether they're going
to have a full meal or any meal
at all.
At the end of that day.
That's not conducive to sitting
in a classroom and going through
an academic experience.
We know that our students are
visiting the counselors at our
help center for mental wellness
at high rates during high stress
periods like exam weeks and at
various points throughout the
year of course.
The fact that most of our
students are working students is
really no coincidence when
looking at these statistics.
It's true that life can get to
be especially hectic for our
students with competing
responsibilities that include --
Working those multiple jobs
maintaining academic achievement
and engaging in professional
activities that are needed to
meet the demands of the present
day work force.
Times have changed.
Not to mention that most
students are local and
contribute to helping their
families and communities as well.
So this makes accessing
resources like the S. I. food
pantry -- Not only helpful but
critical to student success
retention and graduation.
We know that students utilizing
our pantry are often feeding
multiple people.
And we're appreciative of the
money set aside for basic needs
in the governor's budget
Because we really need it.
The pantry saw six thousand
visits so far this year. Ten
thousand people have been fed by
those visits.
In this week alone since we
opened re opened our food pantry
here in our university union.
We have seen three hundred and
forty student visits just this
week alone.
Our highest months all 110030% --
Increase from the previous year.
And if Dodd doesn't demonstrate
the need and the impact of these
resources.
I really don't know what else
does.
As our campus First Lady Jody
Nielsen set herself this
situation is bittersweet.
Because it's good to see
students are being supported.
But it should also not mean that
the scenario is one that we're
stuck with in perpetuity.
I have said this for a while but
these are basic needs after all.
There should be a point where we
start focusing on more than the
base minimum and start to allow
for resources from the campus
community whether it's from a
desire from another local entity.
To go towards high impact
practices like study abroad --
Aid and summered for state.
We know that this is going to
put our students on an equal
playing field.
And we have to start thinking
ahead towards again those things
that come beyond.
I recognize that there's a
hierarchy of needs but public
higher education.
After all be publicly funded and
through a holistic approach
which is why work.
Again.
Very very thankful and honored
that this conversation is
happening.
Now I don't mean to sound like
I'm running for an officer
giving some generic speech but
this is what I really believe
after representing our students
for the past two years.
Is that a significant number of
our students -- For pop you are
vulnerable population within our
state.
I really do think that students
are Holyoke vulnerable
population we're a microcosm of
our state this is largely due to
the rising cost of living and
the rising cost of a public
higher education.
And it goes to the fact that we
know that state investment in
the CSU is comparatively lower
than a couple of decades ago.
And amidst competing funding
priorities we're now in a
situation. For student basic
needs have become a crisis point
in our society.
The thing is you did basic needs
are California's basically it's
just magnified due to
circumstance which I've
mentioned.
This is an intersecting issue
and I hope that we can all see
that.
And as we sit here I'm thinking
of the student parent that's
looking for emergency housing
and can't be placed in a shared
room.
I'm thinking of the undocumented
students who is too afraid to
ask for support and file forms
with their information on it.
I'm thinking of so many students
who feel the sense of urgency
after sleeping in their cars or
showering out origin.
California's university must
serve California and that's why
I'm hopeful that sharing some of
the students stories with you
today here at sac state.
Will help engaging the magnitude
of this problem.
I look forward to hearing more
student voices.
And again I thank you for your
willingness to listen even if
this conversation may sometimes
seem predictable repetitive I
promise you it is neither.
Thank you.
Thank you Mister Moore a great
testimony -- The facts the facts
are are stunning six thousand
visits to the food pantry this
year.
And certainly -- Your bill your
belief that student basic needs
are in a crisis point is
something that I think all of us
share I think that's why we're
here.
So we appreciate your leadership
and your voice and all this
thank you thank you very much.
Next I want to invite.
Sidra -- Mukhtar my pronouncing
your name right okay a student
here at Sacramento state who has
some experiences to share with
us welcome [inaudible]
Thank you.
Good morning -- I am a fourth
year student here at Sacramento
state I was a thirty three point
eight GPA student -- With four
consecutive semesters on the
dean's honors list I came into
my college career with twelve
units on my transcript for my
college units -- But then all
change in my junior year -- I
come from a lot of financial
privilege but also a lot of
abuse.
So when I decided to stand up
against my abuser and leave I
was left with nothing.
No food no place to stay and
transportation her job and very
little money despite all of this
the university supported me and
all of these areas with job
referrals donated bike and cell
phone.
A place an emergency housing
access to the dining Commons M.
A. S. I. food pantry and help
with applying to cal fresh.
All of these Alonso weekly
meetings with Daniel Monning is
one of our case managers to
assess my immediate and changing
needs.
At three point eight GPA dean's
on our list student how also
hope I felt like a complete
failure.
As paralyzed with fear after an
incident of stalking harassment
from my abuser here on campus.
So I stopped attending classes
he gave himself farm how lost
sight of the day I graduate.
The people at this university
including Daniel Monning aus
that's less than and also
anything right.
Just to name a few.
Fully supported me through all
of that as provided with
information of resources in the
community like we've and my
sister's house.
Received an emergency fund from
the university I was connected
with someone in the community
community for housing after the
spring semester what and last
year.
This whole thing counseling
services listen to what I have
to say about my mental health.
After my own doctors in the
community rejected and
stigmatize the word that came
out of my mouth.
This university help me when the
greater Sacramento community let
me down it's so easy to tell our
students. To go find a job be
responsible and pull themselves
out of their basic needs
struggles but you know what a
full time student with a part
time job working nights to talk
about.
And then riding their bike home
at three in the morning is that
going to get them very far.
Employers give too little errors
to their students employees and
the housing market is beyond
reach for at many young adults
try to make it through school
without financial support from
their family.
I've been emergency housing
twice now.
I was I received the find. To
make their own needs me.
I to make their own -- Ends meet
when it comes to housing and
community members who agree to
house you don't want you coming
home at three in the morning
from your seven hour shift that
talk about.
So they tell you that it's not
working out anymore and then you
find yourself back at the mercy
of the university.
I was going to take time off
from school to work at talk
about so that I could afford my
rent and other bills and today
here I am. Eighteen units away
from graduating no longer facing
academic probation and slowly
resuscitating my GPA for
graduate school.
I could have easily fallen Tom
thought minimum wage tropical
but I didn't.
Because of the people here the
sacrament Steve Kerr's office if
I. food pantry and health and
counseling services.
Now I can finally keep working
on my degree go to law school
and get back to the community by
advocating for marginalized
groups.
And I think that my story is a
penny of author Allen -- Brown's
plastic saying that you cannot
pour from an empty vessel thank
you [inaudible]
By.
Did read thank you for sharing
your story it's the powerful
story.
You were one strong person
[inaudible]
And yeah out of this difficulty
and at eighteen minutes you're
almost there.
I know you're gonna you're gonna
stay committed to it and you've
overcome so much and what's most
interesting.
About your story is that if we
look back on it twenty years
[inaudible]
From now -- I hope that you will
say that -- It has made you
stronger more insightful.
A more powerful advocate for
those who share the same
experiences that you have here
because they're not unique you
know.
There's a lot of students who --
I Robert having this same kinds
of challenges that you will
become very very difficult ones --
And that.
At at at at that spiral into a
very difficult place on housing
on food all the things that you
have shared with us and I I feel
the power -- In your testimony
and you.
And it gives me great confidence
that twenty years from now we're
gonna be celebrate your
leadership.
So many ways so we can't give
thanks for sharing that story.
We we want to invite.
Other students here who have
come maybe just to listen and
and that.
React maybe they have value come
with a message that experiences
that you have had but we want to
invite you to share your your
thoughts with us here and in
this hearing.
So if you like to come to one of
the two microphones and Mike
corrected both of them are live.
M. Bynum microphone is that the
your stories -- Your experiences.
You all for being here and for
listening at the for
participating so he tells you
not tell us your name but you up
with us your first name.
Also check that microphone I
don't hear anything there is
there to on and off switch we
can double check on hold on one
second.
Right one more time.
There you go hi my name's Tammy
Lynn and I'm a current
psychology major here at fox
date.
And I am.
Honored to be a student here I'm
formerly incarcerated and I'm
former foster use I grew up in
the system and when I
transferred to sac state I was
almost out of financial aid
because I had.
Basically taught myself to learn
to read and write and had.
To had to tighten up those
skills and community college so
when I got here.
I had about a year left a
financial aid and if it weren't
for the cal grants in the
university grants.
I wouldn't have.
Even been able to start.
And within about two years I was
facing homelessness and I was at
a point where.
I was going to have to leave
school because I couldn't afford
the seven or eight hundred
dollars extra -- On top of the
grant to stay in school every
semester.
And I started reaching out and
found guardian scholars program
and project rebound.
And without those programs I
wouldn't be in school today
graduating in just a few weeks.
And and this campus has been
like a home to me and I really
just want to say that I have
utilized the pantry many times
and still to this day I get my
food from a food bank because I
am on SSI disability and I'm not
allowed to get -- Cal works of
what is it called the the help
right for food they won't give
it to us.
So when I have forty dollars and
left every month for groceries
many times I have to spend out
on gas to get to school.
And I would rather do that
because school is so important
to me.
It's it's my life I have almost
a three point five GPA and I've
maintained that through.
Every single struggle that I've
gone through and I have raised
my grandchildren on my own -- I
also.
An abusive relationship and gone
through many other things.
And I just want to say that -- I
am so grateful for you guys on
what you're doing for it for us
because without -- Making some
changes there there's a lot of
us out here that.
We we can't afford tuition it's
but I can't afford not to go to
school.
Because of the impact that you
know because of a life I came
from I need my education I want
to be able to get back to my
community.
I want to help other students I
just applied for a job in the
cares office and I'm train every
day I get it.
I want to be that one person
that can help people like me --
I'm I'm so grateful for you guys
please keep doing what you're
doing I I couldn't be here
without you thank you Tammy wow.
Another student that's overcome
so many challenges and weeks
away from graduating you've made.
M. great choices and then in the
midst of very hard choices to
get that degree and to get that
this year your career and your
future adhesive.
Graduations.
Thank you over here.
A go so my name is Quinn -- I'm
an art student here at sac state --
I'm born and raised in Stockton
California and moved up to
Sacramento -- Three years ago
now and I'm.
The first person in my family to
pursue a college education.
And yeah yes one six thanks for
the work the doing because it.
Doesn't matter -- I think the
arts are really important part
of the Sacramento community and
I think that -- There's still a
lot to be done in terms of
growing sac state into the
Sacramento archimedean think
that.
Is something that's an ongoing
thing that I'm.
You know hopefully gonna.
Do when I graduate this fall --
Mom when you're off from a from
a four year graduation plan but
I think that's a lot you know
pretty solid.
It's a during I started as a
computer science student at
eighty year that and then I
switched over to your yeah so I
think that.
The the plan that you have.
For discussing in an evaluating
mental illness is a part of
being.
A student is really important --
Some of the experiences that
I've had in the in the arts here
at sac state -- I made
specifically new media work on
computers networking computer
lab.
This semester I'm taking --
Three different studio classes.
It's de a class is three hours
long so some of my Tuesdays are
twelve hours because here on
campus doing work but I love
that one and I'm really happy
that I'm doing it just because I
get to work on these just.
Doing what I'm passionate about --
Also part time employee here at
sac state and this community is
not a lot for me -- When I came
up here? Four years ago I didn't
know why I was here why I was
seeking a college education was
just.
What I was told to do?
But I taken steps because of
this community. To understand
why I'm here and why I am doing.
And why it's important -- So I
want to thank you for the going
work the you doing to to value
we thank thank you when thank
you.
Are you in the Mike.
Yeah go ahead yeah.
Hello everyone my name is --
Flores and I am a going into my
last year at Sacramento state
I'm a communications major -- If
this is in public affairs -- I
do want to thank you guys for
all like for being your first
and foremost -- Also want to
thank you for all the work that
you guys do at the state level --
I think it's very important --
Especially advocating for all
kinds of students not -- To the
group -- So I really use like.
Officially like the yes I would
pan Jim but I do know students
that have gone in and use the
they are able to get food and
like.
You know my brother help press
and be able to receive all that
money -- In order to like make
it through whether it's a month
or you know the next month but I
give them kind of a little bit
less -- Anxiety or kind of
they're going through some kind
of stress -- For me.
My first a little bit more
different because I'm a transfer
student -- After I graduated
high school I went to the
meeting Holly spurs and I
communicable is I was never
really involved -- I didn't
really know how to or I didn't
know the like and what to get
involved in or or I didn't
really see.
Any kind of like anything for me
you know I mean so.
So a committee college I didn't
really get involved -- Actually
de I stopped going to committee
college because my family was
going to a financial hardship --
It was only me my sister my mom
so that was kind of one of the
hardest parts of my life was --
My mom was working like two jobs --
My fishes finishing high school --
I'm trying to work.
Part Wilk full time and full
time student which was really
you know really hard for me
because I was a child my mom out.
With pan around her bills -- And
things like that so that was I
was a financial hardship that we
went there was actually dropped
out of school for about a year.
And it was.
Interesting because I got to see
the perspective of light will my
wife could be at if I didn't you
know come back to school -- I
saw myself I was working in the
construction zone -- I don't
think I mentioned it but I am
with -- Doctor students I am a
dreamer -- So I was facing like
on top of everything that I was
facing like I have Bates -- Just
like.
Everything else with the country --
Because I was brought here when
I was like four years old and it
was not like it's not like I had --
A say in the light coming to the
US is just you know my parents
ended up bringing here -- For a
better life [inaudible]
So -- Once I saw my life in the
construction zone you know my
body was really deteriorating I
was actually doing a demolition.
So it was just like.
Our word we can about like where
I am coming back home at like
six PM then literally eating and
then go back to sleep -- But I
did that for about a year.
And I saw my wife and I was like.
You know I don't do this forever
I don't want to do this for all
they need to go back to school --
I went back to college finished
of any college.
Thanks a and honestly like I say
like.
I one of the best things I've
ever done in my life -- I want
to think like all the back until
the staff on and any student
there's now it's like.
Of the five stages provides that
like.
W. I. N. even like I'm from
Sacramento on like even when
Mike I'm not at home like I'm a
home here.
And like for me like I spend SXT
like at least.
Like on a day to you know
bouncing on my classes my work --
Socializing probably get
fourteen hours a day so like get
here around -- Either seven AM.
Zero eight PM I don't know
whatever time but I just want to
say like.
The the program they really help
me out with a dream research
centering on campus -- When I
transferred over I really had no
idea on?
On a lot of things -- Just.
I was kind of going into a long
so once I came in -- The Jim
research center actually really
helped me out into.
A whether it's financial aid it
was getting -- I actually got.
I didn't apply for the the
hooting Rampone for the one that
says they but I did apply to the
dream research center they have
their own personal -- One so
they did help me in order to get
paper schools for the first
semester.
I think that was really.
Like I was really grateful that
they were able to do that for me --
The only thing that I want to
say like I hope you guys take
into consideration -- Those next
wave of students are going to be
coming in -- Because we don't
know that right now like as does
the United States like the
policy Bob like they're not
accepting new recipients for the
doctor dreamers the so.
All those -- Like students are
gonna be coming in.
Into a light.
Whether they want to go to
college or not like they might
not have the opportunity because
like they're not accepting --
The like the the mac
applications so in order to do
receive you make you must have
like a five five bill I'm.
I believe and if you're not like
receiving any financial aid then
like all those new wave of
students that.
Are not able to apply propelled
rounds they're not able -- To
get like scholarship defining
for them just because
technically they're undocumented --
Compared to me where I'm I'm a
little bit you know I'm really
grateful that I do have this
opportunity to to be able to
apply and get most of it paid
although I don't get it all but
just want to say like.
Just take into consideration
rails -- The students -- And
thank you for everything there
is to thank you Israel thank you
thanks for sharing your story.
Okay here yes.
Hi good morning my name is in
him again I'm a fourth year here
at Saks dot tell me your name
again.
Yeah yeah okay -- As a student
has struggled with basic needs I
wanted to mention that there is
a proposal.
In the legislative for twenty
million an ongoing fines for
rapid re housing for college
students that students would let
me support on and then also I
had a question for stern
remember McCarty.
So I don't know.
Yeah he had to get to a budget
hearing actually.
When you can ask your question
will pass it on to him okay so
my question basically was --
That he mentioned he has a bill
I work for financial aid and
help solve the problem students
are facing with the total cost
of attendance.
How will that will solve the
specific issue?
Rate will pass I don't know the
answer to that I will pass it on
to him.
Thank you Cynthia okay yes Sir.
Hi my name is Jeremiah merece
I'm graduating in two weeks with
a masters of public policy
administration I just wanted to
briefly discuss some policies.
I'm also currently serving as a
research assistant to UC regent
Michael Cohen.
So I've been studying basic
needs for him for the last few
months and so I wanted to share
some of the things I've learned
at the UC is doing that's also
relevant to this issue and
community colleges so -- It's
not the same Mike it is yeah
remember doctor finance mobile
going.
Not Donald trump's microphone
right.
Norris so.
So I think that we need to
continue working to get the cal
fresh application into the
financial aid process on the way
we're signing up students.
Finding a legibility up front.
And we need to continue working
that until we can instill that
federally under a different
administration when it becomes
more friendly to do -- I think
that's something that we need
our state leaders to push the
next secretary of education.
Under democratic -- Leadership
to do -- I think next is.
Once we are able to scale up how
fresh we need to be able to make
sure our counties have the
capability to do it some
counties have outdated software
systems aren't able to do it
others just don't have the
manpower political well.
That's something I've seen
through the U. sees that they've
experienced a couple of counties.
So -- They think.
Moreover we've been consistent
baseline of services the UC is
trying to deal with this right
and that right now in their
funding allocation -- I think
that.
Last week's L. airport one basic
needs for the U. sees -- The
governor's proposed budget on it.
It rightly points out the
inconsistent inconsistency
unfairness between community
colleges and C. issues with what
the C. issues down so far.
A granite they've got their
research models and everything
but we need to make sure we get
those baseline services up
across the board.
Especially because of the need
this disproportionate me -- And
lastly housing is by far the
biggest challenge that we face
in the whole state facing it.
And I think that if you're all
about.
Finding efficiency in the state
dollars you start looking at off
campus shared housing between
the systems.
So some of our communities
across the state.
Those opportunities exist
Sacramento San Diego bay area.
You could put off campus housing
in west Iraq.
Into the transportation network
being students to Sacramento and
also to Davis into Los Rios.
As well so so I can use to exist
I would like to see you guys
great weather.
You can also use the **** to
facilitate that because cancel
government government's yes
great you're Mike thank you
thanks for being here thank
[inaudible]
Yes ma'am.
Hello -- Thank you for the
opportunity. To talk to you guys.
A young lady reporter and
everything inside of me and your
story is completely inspiring
and thank you for sharing your
story -- For myself -- I would
like to think that I'm not your
typical student -- High school
drop out -- Get your diploma at
twenty one teenage mother --
Starting school in your thirties --
On every subsidized program that
they have to offer -- When I
came I'm a transfer student --
When I started school at the --
Junior college -- I didn't
really go to graduate but yet
here I am -- I was encouraged to
come to Saks state.
My first semester was. To say
the least -- What I wanted to
expand this story at -- Amazing
yet.
Tremendously scary a semester --
I start off this semester.
Before the semester even started
I found out I had breast cancer
so I had to go through this
whole surgery thing and I was
like I'm.
One I came this far nothing's
gonna breast cancer is not gonna
stop me that was my attitude --
So -- Needless to say -- I went
to the and when I went to that
process -- We work financially
ready. To to to to go through
the medical issues that -- I had
I will I'm on that and the
sacramental -- Section eight
program and so my income with my
rate was low at the time.
When I decide to come back to
school I had to pick up extra
jobs and so I worked a lot to
try to catch up for all those
bills?
That was behind so -- When it
was time to submit my income
they said -- Good you can pay
more rent and they went from.
Four hundred to fourteen hundred
and it within a month a couple
of months I had to figure out
how to pay that we although I
didn't have the income to do
that which landed me in a
position where -- León homeless
was a threat -- That wouldn't
have been the first time I've
been homeless before but I don't
need to go back that far this is
curry -- Currently -- I'm in the
process of trying to figure out
how.
To fight to have policies
changed because I have friends
that's going to transfer here in
their mothers with children and
you know we have to work and
we're not your average still
naked take fifteen units we you
know some of us have to take six
units. Four nine units on the
I'm on twelve units right now
and I'm just like Diane what's
your major life what's your
major -- For my bachelors degree
my goal is deaf studies -- I
started sign language at the
junior college -- And I have a
whole purpose in the rhyme and
reason for that but I'm here now
doing that Margolis social work
for my masters degree.
And currently when the mind
frame that I would love to get
my doctorate degree I decided
that when I was here.
You might not agree in sociology
but you know that I'm being led
by whatever you know whatever
way the wind blows but I'm going
to keep pushing -- I said all I
have to say is -- I don't know
what policies and it was
interesting to see Richard pan
because I was actually going to
reach out to his office this
week -- What policies they have
for a transition -- Currently
there's really not a transition
if you're on section eight if
you're on how works if you're on
snap on food stamps.
You -- You start off at a
certain level and when you say
I'm trying to work to do a
little better they say.
You can do it yourself and they
kind of cut off the system.
Are there are there the way
their policies is set up they
just kind of cut to offer they
around from you know like they
did with me for four seventy
four to fourteen hundred with no
transition.
And I would like to know -- From --
While the rich enough his office
but you guys -- As well how do
we eliminate that because every
single time I think about
quitting college everything
inside of me falls apart and I
do struggle with depression and
anxiety and whenever I think
about that -- It it.
That's what it does to me yeah
because I became so far and I
don't give that.
Card to to to have to quit
because I cannot financially
afford anything -- God has
placed me in the in the in the
hands of the right people -- The
care program with Danielle and
there's listen all the M. that
kinda like no we're all you're
not going to quit you're not
gonna give out we have these
programs the O. P. program we
have these programs that will
help you.
Get through -- And and just for
the one time offering you know
to help me catch up on my the
eight hour notice is in my car
insurance is that's canceling my
registration. For while I'm
trying to go to school and
maintain my four point oh for my
first semester god knows I'm
just like how my gonna get a
four point oh this semester
because so many things is going
on so -- I would like to know
and it would be also Mike nice
to know what the college my how
do you help with that transition
period when you're trying to
work as a student.
You're just trying to make ends
meet but they tell you make too
much you know and so I just want
thank you for the opportunity.
And is really good thanks for
coming and sharing your story.
That's that's that's persistence
and I hope that it's always stay
strong and stay strong you come
so far.
And and it's only gonna get
better even though these are big
challenges still and by the way
your normal to be stressed okay.
We get stressed hi we have one
last speaker and then we're
gonna go out and see the fair
that's outside.
The focus is on some of these
issues but hello welcome and but
hi my name is our shells are --
First what is what is it thank
you so much for being here and
listening to you know all those
students are here.
I think for me growing up --
Education was.
Going to school was where I felt
the most liberated. For me it
was a liberating experience -- I
don't really understand -- The
depth of a financial turbulence
until I came to succeed -- But I
think that we have such a
wonderful Hornet family here.
Thank you so much Daniel windows
for doing the work that you do.
Thank you so much for creating
and and working with all.
Trying to come out all these
different charges that we're
we're facing.
I'm you know I spent the last
about six seven months just.
Kind of speaking and and serving
students and listening to the
concerns because it's such a a
part of who I am right now -- I
I did want to just take out the
time to say this to students
because I sometimes we don't --
We think that we're not enough
like this upcoming month I will
be able to pay my rent.
You just call shipped out I
receive through inside -- And
I'm not a four point oh student
I've actually just been
struggling immensely for the
last.
Year and a half -- Due to not
being able to find a job but I
think that we have.
So much in please and in service
to help students like me -- But
it but what but I did want to
point and see this thought.
The financial aid -- System
unfortunately is a broken system
right we we protect our buttons
but we don't protect our
students -- Students coming here
shouldn't feel and this is
actually speaking for
traditional and nontraditional
students because even if you
have families are hoping you --
They're coming out graduating
with loans.
And I think that the country
itself needs.
To re write the way education
works the financial aid system
has.
Kind of state same place for
last fifty years I think this is
what needs to be combat it
heavily.
Thank you so much thank you
thank you.
Well [inaudible]
Financial.
Same in the cost of yeah eighty
nine eighty nine thirty is you
know we're trying to work on
decreasing tuition but I just
think you know all everyone
being here -- All their
struggles like all those matters
but thank you so much for
everything thank you for sharing
your stories at we came to
Sacramento state for a reason
and it's clear -- As it is
anyone who sat through that.
This hearing which is that these
are all very important.
Personal stories that were the
real it's not about -- Ivory
tower understanding of the
problem it's it's it's on the
ground understanding what
students are going through and
how we can.
Do a better job not just of
recognizing the problems with
doing our own work.
Bill in the Senate then the
assembly within the
administration -- To to try to
make it better -- Let me just
say as in summing I wanna thank
center Allen center pan for
joining me today.
Is the only member Burkhart
McCarty and his leadership in
the assembly is really the one
of the most important.
People in Sacramento because he
chose the budget committee --
For higher education and that's
critically important for us. To
to do more -- That said that so
needed -- The meat thank
etcetera for sharing your story
very powerful as as many of the
other students to share their
stories today -- You've had such
resilience.
And such courage -- And I I
appreciated what you said in
terms of the sac state family
really rally around you and that
that's speaks.
To the good work of fighting
Leeson.
I have you and your staff with a
joy -- Stewart James what you do.
Certainly Lisa who gave us a
tour of the Cathleen center
today her leadership they're
making a difference -- No well
Morrell thank you for the
students that to the leadership
of the of the students.
After being a voice always
always -- In the capital here on
the campus -- But you
collectively bring that voice in
that power to that voice and and
the work that we do.
And it's it's critically
important -- And my Leyva
president Nelson.
I love your leadership I know
how roll up your sleeves engaged
you are.
Everybody should know your name
I'm sure they do -- Because
that's the personal touch you
bring to your leadership and I
sighed.
We interviewed you originally
and I see it every day -- And
everybody I I interact with from
the campus so committed to
student success.
You know as well as anyone how.
How life changing a degree can
be -- But the whole family
environment here to help kids --
Help students.
With their life.
With all the complexities of
life and all the challenges that
they face -- It's it's testimony
to the passion that you bring to
your leadership here and I see
it -- And so many ways thank you
thank you for all that you're
doing.
Going from 8% for four four year
graduation rate. To fourteen at
with that believe that it's
going to get up to twenty here
in the next few months.
Eyes is very impressive and a
great example to all your
colleagues and and the other
twenty two campuses of the state
university system.
So I thank everyone for being a
part of this hearing -- It's
it's it continues fourth.
As you heard at the start -- Our
college tour is a two year
engagement process to continue
to hear stories to connect to
learn how we can do our jobs
better is.
Members of the Senate and the
assembly.
And de sac status provided a
great kick off with examples of
excellence.
Accomplishment and stories of
the travail and difficulty that.
To remind each of us -- About
how -- Important the work that
we do every day.
So with that we're going to go
to a basic needs here here on
the campus those who are
listening or watching.
I'll be able to see that -- But
will share some more that those
experiences in the next year and
we have in the coming months so
thank you all for coming.
This meeting